up next president lyndon baines
johnson's 1964 state of the union
address
this speech was delivered just a little
over a month after the assassination of
president john f kennedy the speech is
being shown courtesy of the lyndon
baines johnson presidential library and
museum
mr speaker
the president of the united states
[Applause]
members of the congress
i have the great pleasure
the high privilege and the distinct
honor
of presenting to you
the president
of the united states
miss speaker
[Applause]
speaker
mr president
members of the house and senate
my fellow americans
i will be brief
our time is necessarily short
and our agenda is already long
last year's congressional session was
the longest
in peacetime history
[Applause]
and with that foundation
let us
work together
to make this year's session
the best
in the nation's history
let this session of congress be known
as the session which
did more for civil rights
than the last hundred sessions combined
as the session which enacted the
most far-reaching tax cut
of our time
[Applause]
as the session which declared all-out
war on human poverty
and unemployment in these united states
as the session which finally
recognized
the health needs
of all
of our older citizens
as the session which reformed
our tangle transportation
and transit policies
[Applause]
as the session which achieved
the most effective efficient
foreign aid program ever
and as the session which
helped to build more homes
and more schools
and more libraries
and more hospitals
than any single session of congress
in the history of our republic
all this
and more
can
and must be done
it can be done
by this summer
[Applause]
and it can be done
without any increase in spending
[Applause]
in fact
under the budget that i shall shortly
submit
it can be done with an actual
reduction in federal expenditures and
federal employment
we have in 1964
a unique opportunity and obligation
to prove
the success
of our system
to disprove those cynics and critics at
home and abroad
who question our purpose
and our competence
if we fail
if we fritter and fumble away our
opportunity
in needless senseless quarrels
between democrats
and republicans
are between the house
and the senate
are between the south
and the north
or between the congress and the
administration
then history will rightfully
judge us harshly
but if we succeed
if we can achieve these goals by forging
in this country
a greater sense of union
then
and only then
can we take full satisfaction
in the state of the union
here in the congress you can demonstrate
effective legislative leadership
by discharging the public business
with clarity and dispatch
voting each important proposal up
are voting it down
but at least bringing it to a fair and a
final vote
let us carry forward the plans and
programs
of john fitzgerald kennedy not because
of our sorrow
our sympathy
but because
they are right
and in his memory today
i especially ask all members of my own
political faith
in this election year
[Applause]
to put your country ahead of your party
and to always debate principles
never debate personalities
[Applause]
for my part
i pledge a progressive administration
which is efficient
and honest
and frugal
the budget to be submitted to the
congress shortly
is in full accord with this pledge
it will
cut our deficit
in half
[Applause]
from 10 billion dollars to 4 billion 900
million dollars
[Applause]
it will be in proportion to our national
output
the smallest budget since 19 and 51.
[Applause]
it will call for a substantial reduction
in federal employment
[Applause]
a feat accomplished only once before in
the last 10 years
while maintaining the full strength
of our combat defenses
it will call for the lowest number
of civilian personnel
in the department of defense since 1950
[Applause]
it will call for total expenditures of
97 billion
900 million
compared to 98 billion
400 million for the current year a
reduction of more than 500 million
dollars
it will call for new obligation
authority
of a hundred and three billion eight
hundred million
a reduction of more than four billion
dollars
below last year's request
of 107 billion 900 million
[Applause]
but it is not a stand-still budget for
america cannot afford to stand still
our population is growing
our economy is more complex
our people's needs are expanding
but by closing down obsolete
installations
by curtailing less urgent programs
by cutting back where cutting back seems
to be wise
by insisting
on a dollar's worth
or a dollar spent
[Applause]
i am able to recommend in this reduced
budget the most
federal support in history
for education
[Applause]
for help
[Applause]
for retraining the unemployed
and for helping the economically and the
physically handicapped
this budget
and this year's legislative program
are designed to help each and every
american citizen
fulfill his basic hopes
his hopes for a fair chance to make good
his hopes for fair play from the law
his hopes for a full-time job on
full-time faith
his hopes for a decent home for his
family
in a decent
community
his hopes for a good school for his
children
with good teachers
and his hopes for security
when faced with sickness
or unemployment
our old age
unfortunately
many
americans
over on the of hope
some because of their poverty
and some because of their color
and all too many
because of both
our task
is to help
replace their despair
with opportunity
and this administration today
here and now
declares unconditional war on poverty in
america
and i
urge this congress and all americans
to join with me
in that effort
[Applause]
it will not be a short or easy struggle
single weapon or strategy strategy will
suffice
but we shall not rest until that war is
won
the richest nation on earth
can afford to win it
we cannot afford to lose it
one thousand dollars invested in
salvaging
an unemployable youth
today
can return forty thousand dollars or
more in his lifetime
poverty is a national problem
requiring improved national organization
and support
but this attack to be effective must
also be organized at the state and the
local level
and must be supported
and directed by state and local efforts
[Applause]
for the war against poverty will not be
won here in washington
it must be one in the field
in every private home
in every public office from the
courthouse
to the white house
[Applause]
the program i shall propose will
emphasize this cooperative approach
to help that one-fifth of all american
families
with incomes
too small
to even meet their basic needs
our chief weapons in a more pinpointed
attack
will be better schools
and better health
and better homes and better training and
better job
opportunities to help more americans
especially young americans
escape from squalor
and misery
and unemployment roles where other
citizens helped to carry them
very often a lack of jobs and money
is not the cause of poverty
but the symptom
the cause may lie deeper in our failure
to give our fellow citizens
a fair chance to develop their own
capacities
in a lack of education and training
a lack of medical care and housing in a
lack of decent communities in which to
live and bring up their children but
whatever the cause
our joint federal local effort
must pursue poverty
pursue it wherever it exists
in city slums in small towns
in share proper shacks are in migrant
worker camps
on indian reservations
among whites
as well as negro
among the young as well as the aged
in the boom towns and in the depressed
areas
our aim is not only to relieve the
symptom of poverty
but to cure it
and above all
to prevent
[Applause]
no single piece of legislation however
is going to suffice
we will launch a special effort
in the chronically distressed areas of
appalachia
we must expand our small but our
successful area redevelopment program
we must enact youth employment
legislation to put jobless aimless
hopeless younger youngsters to work on
useful projects
we must distribute more food to the
needy through a broader food stamp
program
[Applause]
we must create a national service corps
to help the economically handicapped of
our own country
as the peace corps now helps those
abroad
we must modernize our unemployment
insurance and establish a high level
commission on automation
if we have the brain power
to invent these machines
we have the brain power to make certain
that they are a boon and not a vein to
humanity
we must extend the coverage of our
minimum wage laws to more than 2 million
workers now lacking this basic
protection of purchasing power
we must by including special school aid
funds as part of our education program
improve the quality of teaching and
training and counseling in our hardest
hip areas
[Applause]
we must build more libraries in every
area and more hospitals and nursing
homes under the hill burton act and
train more nurses to staff them
we must provide hospital insurance for
our older citizens financed by every
worker and his employer under social
security
[Applause]
contributing no more than one dollar a
month during the employees working
career
to protect him
in his old age
in a dignified manner
without cost to the treasury
against the devastating hardship
of prolonged or repeated illness
[Applause]
we must
as a part of a revised housing and urban
renewal program
give more help to those displaced by
slum clearance
provide more housing for our poor and
our elderly
and seek as our ultimate goal in our
free enterprise system
a decent home
for every american family
we must help
obtain more modern mass transit
within our communities as well as low
cost transportation between them
above all
we must release
billion dollars of tax reduction
into the private spending stream
to create new jobs
and new markets in every area of this
land
these programs are obviously not for the
poor
or the underprivileged alone
every american will benefit
by the extension of social security
to cover the hospital costs of their
aged parents
every american community will benefit
from the construction and modernization
of schools and libraries and hospitals
and nursing homes
from the training of more nurses and
from the improvement of urban renewal
and public transit
and every individual american taxpayer
and every corporate taxpayer
will benefit from the earliest possible
passage of the pending tax bill
from both the new investment it will
bring
and the new jobs that it will create
[Applause]
that tax bill has been
thoroughly
discussed for a year
[Applause]
now
we need action
the new budget
clearly allows it
[Applause]
our taxpayers surely
deserve it
[Applause]
our economy strongly demands it
[Applause]
and every month
of delay
dilutes its benefits in 1964
for consumption
for investment
and far
employment for until the bill is signed
its investments incentives cannot be
deemed certain
and the withholding rate cannot be
reduced
and the most damaging and devastating
thing you can do to any businessman in
america
is to keep him in doubt
and to keep him guessing on what our tax
policy is
and i say that we should now
reduce to 14
instead of 15
our withholding rate
and i therefore urge the congress
to take final action on this bill
by the first of february if at all
possible
[Applause]
or however proud we may be of the
unprecedented progress of our free
enterprise economy over the last three
years
we should not and we cannot
permit it to pause
in 1963 for the first time in history
we crossed the 70 million job mark
but we will soon need more than 75
million jobs
in 1963 our gross national product
reached the 600 billion level
100 billion higher
than when we took office
but it easily could and it should be
still 30 billion higher today than it is
wages and profits and family income
are also at their highest level in
history
but i would remind you that 4 million
workers
and 13 percent of our industrial
capacity are still idle today
we need a tax cut now to keep this
country moving
[Applause]
for our goal is not merely to spread the
work our goal is to create more jobs
i believe the enactment of a 35-hour
week
would sharply increase costs
would invite inflation
would impair our ability to compete
and merely share
instead of creating employment
but i am equally opposed to the 45 or
50-hour week
in those industries where consistently
excessive use of overtime causes
increased unemployment
[Applause]
so therefore i recommend
legislation authorizing the creation of
a triparta
industry committee to determine on an
industry-by-industry basis
as to where a higher penalty rate for
overtime would increase job openings
without unduly increasing costs
and authorizing the establishment of
such higher rates
let me make one principle of this
administration abundantly clear
all of these increased opportunities in
employment and education and housing
and in every field
must be open to americans of every color
as far as the writ of federal law will
run
we must abolish not some
but all racial discrimination
[Applause]
or this is not merely an economic issue
or a social political or international
issue
it is a moral issue
and it must be met by the passage this
session
of the bill now pending in the house
all members of the public should have
equal access to
facilities open to the public
all members of the public should be
equally eligible for federal benefits
that are financed by the public
all members of the public should have an
equal chance to vote for public
officials and to send their children to
good public schools
and to contribute their talents to the
public good
[Applause]
today
americans of all races
stand side by side in berlin and in
vietnam
they died side by side in korea
surely
they can work
and eat
and travel
side by side in their own country
[Applause]
[Music]
we must also lift by legislation the
bars of discrimination against those who
seek entry into our country
particularly those with much needed
skills
and those joining their families
in establishing preferences
a nation that was built by the
immigrants of all lands
can ask those who now seek admission
what can you do
for our country
but we should not be asking
in what country were you born
for our ultimate goal
is a world without war
a world made safe for diversity
in which all men goods and ideas
can freely move across every border and
every boundary
we must advance toward this goal in 1964
in at least 10 different ways
not as partisans
but as patriots
first
we must
maintain and our reduced defense budget
will maintain
that margin of military safety and
superiority
obtained through three years of steadily
increasing both the quality and the
quantity of our strategic
our conventional and our anti-gorilla
forces
[Applause]
in 1965
we will be better prepared
than ever before
to defend the cause of freedom
whether it's threatened by outright
aggression
or by the
infiltration practiced by those in hanoi
and havana who ship arms and men across
international borders to full man
insurrection
[Applause]
and we must continue to use that
strength
as john kennedy used it in the cuban
crisis
and for the test ban treaty
to demonstrate both the futility of
nuclear war
and the possibilities
of lasting peace
[Applause]
second we must take new steps
and we shall make new proposals
at geneva
towards the control and the eventual
abolition of arms
even in the absence of agreement
we must not stockpile arms beyond our
needs
our seek an excess of military power
that could be provocative as well as
wasteful and it is in this spirit
that in this fiscal year
we are cutting back
our production of enriched uranium by 25
we are shutting down
four plutonium piles
we are closing many
non-essential military installations
and it is in this spirit
that we today call on our adversaries to
do the same
[Applause]
third
we must make increased use of our food
as an instrument of peace
making it available by sale our trade
our loan or donation
to hungry people
in all nations
which tell us of their needs
and accept proper conditions of
distribution
[Applause]
fourth we must assure our preeminence in
the peaceful exploration of outer space
focusing on an expedition to the moon in
this decade
in cooperation with other powers if
possible
alone if necessary
[Applause]
fifth we must expand world trade
having recognized the act of 1962 that
we must buy
as well as sell we now expect our
trading partners
to recognize that we must sell
as well as buy
[Applause]
we are willing to give them competitive
access to our market
asking only
that they do the same for us
sixth we must continue through such
measures as the interest equalization
tax
as well as the cooperation of other
nations
our recent progress toward balancing our
international accounts
this administration must
and will
preserve the present gold value of the
dollar
seventh
we must become better neighbors with the
free states of the americas
working with the council of the oas
with a stronger alliance for progress
and with all the men and women of this
hemisphere
who really believe in liberty
and justice for all
eight we must strengthen the ability of
free nations everywhere
to develop their independence and raise
their standard of living and thereby
frustrate those who prey on poverty and
chaos
to do this
the rich must help the poor
and we
must do our part
we must achieve a more rigorous
administration of our development
assistance
with larger roles for private investors
or other industrialized nations
and for international agencies
and for the recipient nations themselves
ninth
we must strengthen our atlantic and
pacific partnership
maintain our alliances and make the
united nations a more effective
instrument for national independence
and international order
[Applause]
hemp and finally
[Applause]
we must develop with our allies
new means of bridging the gap between
the east and the west
facing danger boldly
wherever danger exists
but being equally bold
in our search
for new agreements
which can enlarge the hopes of all
while violating
the interests of none
[Applause]
in short i would say to the congress
that we must be constantly prepared for
the worst and constantly acting for the
best
[Applause]
we must be strong enough to win
any war
and we must be wise enough
to prevent one
[Applause]
we shall neither act as aggressors
nor tolerate acts of aggression
[Applause]
we intend to bury no one
and we do not intend to be buried
we can fight
if we must
as we have fought before
but we pray that we will never have to
fight again
[Applause]
my good friends and my fellow americans
and these last seven sorrowful weeks
we have learned and knew that nothing is
so enduring as faith
and nothing is so degrading as hate
john kennedy was a victim of hate
but he was also a great builder of faith
faith in our fellow americans
whatever their creed or their color or
their station in life
faith in the future of man
whatever his divisions and differences
this faith was echoed
in all parts of the world
on every continent and in every land to
which may johnson and i traveled
we found faith
and hope
and love toward this land
of america
and toward our people
so i ask you now
in the congress
and in the country to join with me
in expressing and fulfilling that faith
in working for a nation
a nation that is free from want
and a world
that is free from hate
[Applause]
a world of peace
and justice
and
freedom and abundance
for our time
and for all time to come
uh
good
every weekend on c-span 3 experience
american history tv